sie wollen verhindern dass die Debatte
um Waffen aus den Fugen gerät Leipzig
will Leuchten für den Frieden 90 Jahre
nach dem Tag an dem Hitler nach der
Macht Griff dort wo 89 die friedliche
Revolution ihren Anfang nahm jetzt wo
Deutschland wieder streitet über Krieg
und Frieden
es hat bei stahlhemmen ganz am Anfang
angefangen und das ging immer weiter und
ich kann das verstehen ich kann das
verstehen das Volk ist in einer Lage da
muss man helfen
Panzer zu schicken wie geht's Ihnen
damit nicht gut weil ich allgemein kein
Fan von Kriegen bin ich habe Angst
ehrlich gesagt das ist irgendwie dadurch
schlimmer wird
am Rande der Kundgebung tummeln sich
links die die aus engsten Wut werden
lassen
rechtsextreme
Verschwörungstheoretiker wie weit soll
deutsche Militärhilfe gehen Sachsens
Ministerpräsident weiß dass diese Frage
gerade hier spaltet und will nicht dass
der rechte Rand von Ängsten profitiert
bei diesem Thema nicht nur eine Meinung
und die Vergewisserung oder dich selbst
in Frage stellen ist doch bei einem
Thema Wie krieg und Frieden absolut
notwendig natürlich haben die Menschen
Angst vor dem Waffenlieferungen
es geht eine Riss durch Deutschland
Leopard 2 Panzer für die Ukraine gut die
Hälfte 54% der deutschen finden das
richtig im Osten aber nur 35 Prozent im
Westen sind es 59
Ulm und Umgebung hier ballen sich
Rüstungsbetriebe die ihr Geschäft gerade
massiv ausbauen vom Schmuddelkind zum
Hoffnungsträger avanciert sind
kürzlich hat Olaf Scholz modernste
Radarsysteme bestaunt
wir sehen sofort bekommt das her von Ulm
aus koordiniert die NATO alle
europäischen Truppen und
materialbewegungen
Bedenken oder Angst sind hierbei nur
wenigen zu spüren in einem
fairtrade-café versucht Thomas Reh mit
bekannte davon zu überzeugen dass Krieg
und Waffen im Moment die einzig richtige
Lösung sind
momentan diktiert Putin uns die Sprache
des Krieges von daher sind wir leider
gezwungen auf kriegerischen Weise zu
antworten
diese Panzer jetzt zufrieden in der
Ukraine sorgen Panzer schießen ja nicht
ja aber die Panzer schießen ja nicht aus
Willkür sondern weil sie geschossen
werden und wir unterstützen die
ukrainische Armee in ihrem Kampf für die
Ukraine und letzten Endes wenn man
diesen Gedanken konsequent zu Ende führt
sind da
noch andere Waffengattungen auch möglich
also Stichwort Kampfflugzeuge auch im
SPD debattencamp in Dresden diskutieren
sie über die Kriegsgefahr hier versucht
die Parteispitze ihre Mitglieder für den
Regierungskurs zu begeistern es gilt
Argumente zu liefern gegen die Angst
diese Angst wie
irgendwann die
die Russen zurückschlagen werden die ist
berechtigt und damit müssen wir rechnen
und wir sind
nah an der Grenze wenn man wenn man da
dieses große russland sieht ist auch ein
stolzes Land und Putin daher irgendwie
ein bisschen irre ist in meinem meine
Wahrnehmung weiß man nie wie er reagiert
die Frage nach Alternativen passt nicht
jedem im Saal was macht die Politik um
immer mit der Ruhe alles gut wir dürfen
alle reden bitte was macht die Politik
um eine friedliche Lösung wieder
anzustreben nochmal diese Debatte muss
erlaubt sein aber putin ist derjenige
der sich verabschiedet hat aus dem Spiel
wenn man Putin lässt schnauft er
vielleicht zwei drei Jahre durch aber
dann wird er weitermachen da hat sich
was verschoben in der parteienlogik
während Anhänger der Regierungsparteien
und der Union die Leopard 2 Lieferungen
mehrheitlich richtig finden sind linke
und AFD eher dagegen überraschend 75%
Panzer Befürworter ausgerechnet bei
grünen Kirchheim unter Teck
baden-Württembergs Ministerpräsident
besucht den Kreisverband sie diskutieren
über vieles Klima Kita-Plätze Kampf
gegen Bürokratie aber eins steht fest
dass die Ukraine Waffen braucht
Tafel steht für Essen je mehr Panzer die
Ukraine bekommt desto besser die Ukraine
muss nicht nur die ihr Land verteidigen
sondern die müssen den Krieg gewinnen
ein leises Grummeln verspüren höchstens
ältere Parteimitglieder
ich habe mich selber gewundert dass ich
plötzlich für Wasser bin aufgrund von
Putins Krieg bisher konnte mir das nicht
vorstellen dass ich so bin weil früher
war ich nicht so die grüne
rekordzustimmung für schwere Waffen
womöglich liegt sie daran dass die
Parteispitzen kaum Platz für Zweifel
lassen
bin ich persönlich kein Pazifisten und
nie gewesen und diese Frage ist schon
1999 Kosovo Konflikt entschieden worden
da hat es die parteiordentlich
durchgeschüttet haben Sie Verständnis
für die die hadern die sich raushalten
wollen ja Verständnis habe ich da in
gewissen Sinne schon aber folgen kann
ich dem natürlich nicht
eins saß Volker Nick für den Frieden im
Gefängnis er wurde Fahrrad Kurier weil
ihm aufgrund seiner Protest
Vergangenheit der Lehrer Job verwehrt
blieb wenn er seine einstigen grünen
Parteikollegen hört kriegt er das kalte
draußen den Gewehr jetzt nicht Angst hat
dass der Krieg eskaliert hat überhaupt
keine Wahrnehmung von dem was geschieht
was soll man denn sonst machen wenn man
eskalieren wollte die müssen wir genau
so handeln ein Krieg gegen Russland
führen ist gleich bedeutend mit einem
nationalen Selbstmord
wir können nur hoffen dass Putin nicht
atomar eskaliert
die Gegend um Mutlangen 1983 einer der
Hauptschauplätze der Friedensbewegung
die Amerikaner stationieren dort
Pershing 2 Raketen mit Atom Sprengköpfen
Aktivisten wie Volker Nick Block
die WG der Demonstranten die sogenannte
pressehütte ist heute ein
Dokumentationszentrum sie wollten damals
eine Atomkatastrophe verhindern jetzt
sei der Krieg nicht mehr kalt sondern
heiß und trotzdem scheint es außer ihnen
kaum jemanden zu interessieren
Erklärungsversuche
Eskalation ist viel weiter weg es ist
jetzt damals in den 80ern war ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass das tatsächlich ein
Effekt hat auf die Gesellschaft auch
dass man sich vielleicht mehr traut oder
mehr toleriert auf politischer Ebene das
narrativ ist wer gegen Waffenlieferung
ist lässt die Ukraine im Stich
und das will keiner von uns sich sagen
lassen am Abend findet im Nachbarort
eine Mahnwache statt Volker nick will
nicht hingehen weil er fürchtet dass der
protestinstrumentalisiert wird und so
ist es dann auch unter die wenigen
Friedens bewegten mischen sich
Querdenker rechtsextreme und
afd-anhänger mit ihnen wollen die
Veranstalter nichts zu tun haben
die Waffenlieferungen Spalten das Land
und die Frage ist ob es Deutschland
diesmal vermag denen zuzuhören die sich
Sorgen machen und sie von denen zu
trennen die die Ängste missbrauchen
wollen
[Musik]